إنه انتصار للمتشددين في إيران، وهو
فوز للمؤسسة الدينية،
وضربة أخرى لحركة الاحتجاج
التي واجهت حملة قمع وحشية على مدى
الأشهر القليلة الماضية. لقد
عادت شرطة الأخلاق الإيرانية إلى الشوارع
وفقًا للمسؤولين الذين يقولون إنهم
سيحملون  القيام بدوريات منتظمة أيضًا
سيرًا على الأقدام وبسيارات فان وأن
شرطة الآداب ستكون قادرة على إيقاف
أي امرأة أه ترتدي الحجاب بشكل غير لائق
ولا تتبع
قانون الحجاب المثير للجدل في البلاد، أعطهم
تحذيرًا إذا لم يتم اتباع ذلك،
فمن المحتمل أن تواجه هؤلاء النساء
عواقب قانونية  تم تسليط الضوء على شرطة الأخلاق
في دائرة الضوء الدولية
منذ حوالي 10 أشهر عندما أوقفت شرطة الأخلاق في سبتمبر من العام الماضي
امرأة تبلغ من العمر 22 عامًا من ماساميني
وتوفيت بعد عدة أيام في
حجزها. وأشعلت المظاهرات في جميع أنحاء
البلاد وتم الرد عليها بـ
حملة قمع وحشية للغاية، لدينا مقطع فيديو
يظهر لك شرطة الأخلاق
في الشوارع وقد تم تصويره من قبل
صحفيين محليين إذا نظرت عن كثب، نعم
ترى هؤلاء الضباط يقومون بدوريات ولكنك
ترى أيضًا النساء بوقاحة شديدة وبجرأة شديدة
يمشين بالقرب منهن دون غطاء للرأس
حتى أن إحداهن كانت جريئة بما يكفي
للتحدث علنًا ضد هذا أمام الكاميرا،
استمعي، هل تعتقدين أن شرطة الأخلاق
يمكنها منع النساء من عدم ارتداء
الحجاب، ولا يمكنها فرضه كما كان الحال من قبل، حيث أصبح
عدد الأشخاص الذين لا يطيعون الحجاب
مرتفعًا جدًا الآن  لا يمكنهم التعامل
معنا جميعًا، آخر شيء يمكنهم فعله هو استخدام
العنف والقوة ضدنا،
لا يمكنهم فعل ذلك، لقد
انحسرت شرطة الأخلاق إلى حد كبير
من شوارع إيران، ويقول شهود إن
وفاة أميني أشعلت
حركة احتجاجية على مستوى البلاد، لكن
عودتهم جاءت في الوقت المناسب  عندما تسير
العديد من النساء منذ أشهر عديدة
بوقاحة في هذه الشوارع
مرة أخرى دون غطاء للرأس، فإن السؤال هو
هل تستطيع شرطة الأخلاق وضع القطة في
الحقيبة، هل يمكنهم تطبيق قانون الحجاب هذا
بعد أشهر من هذه المظاهرات، وإذا كان الأمر
كذلك، فما مدى عنف هذا التطبيق؟
بعض تلك CNN لندن